listen guys we've we've all been young
right we've all we've all been young and
you know in in your youth sometimes you
get into a little bit of trouble
sometimes you make mistakes you party a
little too much you drink underage maybe
you get suspended from school you join
Isis I mean it happens all these things
I and it just I tell you I got into so
much trouble when I was a kid for
joining Isis my parents they took my
playstation away for a week and my dad
said how many times have I told you not
to join Isis they took the place they
then I was you know I did it again I was
grounded these are just normal childhood
experiences at least that's what some
people seem to think that's that's how
the media is portraying it because the
media has been plastering maybe you've
seen these smiling pictures of a young
Muslim woman and her toddler son all
over the place online and they they're
telling us that this woman named Hoda
Musa know who's 24 now she was born in
America
she joined Isis when she was 19 and but
she's learned her lesson now and so she
wants to come home you know four or five
years later she wants to come home and
she's getting a lot of sympathetic
coverage but she she again she abandoned
her family and and left the US a year
after graduation at the high school here
she went to school here had a seemingly
normal life and she went off and joined
Isis became a major propagandist for
them tried to recruit she recruited
other people she used the internet to
recruit other people to join Isis as
well she got married to an Isis fighter
and then he died and then she got
married again and he died too and then
she got married a third time and he also
died I think at this point it seems the
universe is sending you a message and
the message probably is don't marry Isis
fighters you dimwit but now she's she's
in a refugee camp somewhere and the
darling wants to come home and she she's
she she says she's changed she's learned
her lesson but that mean old Donald
Trump along with Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo they say she's not allowed to
come home she they well this isn't even
really her home they say she's not
technically a citizen and she's not
welcome here anymore so she's not
allowed to come back and this is being
portrayed as some kind of like cruelty
but it's some kind of some kind of
cruelty on the part of Donald Trump and
Mike Pompeo and the government that they
won't let this woman come home to what
she says is her home then this is where
her family is and her life was before
she went off and joined Isis but
actually this is this is really merciful
on the part of Donald Trump keep in mind
that Obama had a US citizen executed by
drone strike when he went off and joined
al Qaeda and then he had the guy's
teenage son who I think was 16 years old
at the time
had him executed - so in comparison to
that this is extremely lenient I mean
she because she could be getting the
drone strike treatment but instead
instead it's they're just telling her
don't come back but the thing that is
interesting to me about this about this
topic is that it brings up an
interesting conversation about the
nature of forgiveness and this is one
thing that annoys me I know that it will
surprise you to learn that I'm annoyed
by something I don't get annoyed by
things fair use I can't even say that
with a straight face
but so this is one of the many things
that annoys me is the way that this
concept of forgiveness is is abused and
misused and we use this word of
forgiveness all the time and I think we
use it in a way that shows that we we
don't really understand what the word
means because there are people arguing
and saying well we should have
forgiveness to it towards this towards
this young woman and let her come home
and you know what that's fine you have
have all the forgiveness towards her
that you won't forgive her all you want
okay so if you want
to forgive Hoda leuphana you're
perfectly free to do that and you can go
outside and shout to the sky I forgive
you Hoda and maybe she'll hear the
message in her dreams at night I don't
know but if you want to forgive on a
personal level you absolutely can do
that
the thing is though especially for the
perspective of the government forgiving
someone does not erase what they did
it's not like Groundhog's Day and you
wake up and and it's as if the past
never happened and everything is reset
like some kind of videogame okay that's
that's not the way it works because if
you do something in you then you say
you're sorry and someone forgives you
you still did that thing like the thing
still happened it's it's still there in
the past so if you steal from me I might
forgive you hopefully I forgive you but
if you come back the next day after
apologizing and asked to borrow a
hundred dollars I'm not gonna give it to
you why was my forgiveness incomplete or
fraudulent no but I don't have amnesia
either and I know that this apparently
is something that you struggle with it
is instinct to steal so I'm not going to
entrust my money or my property or my
valuables to you I'm going to exercise
prudence and caution and those things
are not mutually exclusive from
forgiveness you can be cautious prudent
and also forgive if somebody molest a
child we can be as forgiving as we want
as difficult as that I I admit in that
case it's very difficult for me to feel
any forgiveness at all but even if we do
have forgiveness to a child molestor all
the forgiveness in the world should not
in my opinion ever mean letting the
person out of prison I think everyone
that molest children should go to prison
forever at a minimum because now we know
that they have that in them they have
that potential and so for the sake of
prudence for the sake of justice for the
sake of safety of self-defense
of of protecting other children they
need to be in prison forever because
they have that in them they have that
that inclination which does not just die
away when they ask for forgiveness some
actions have consequences that are
permanent even if everybody in the world
forgives you the consequence can still
remain a serial adulterer is probably
going to lose his marriage even if his
wife somehow finds in it within herself
to forgive him that doesn't mean the
damage can be undone the damage is still
there you still destroyed your marriage
no matter how sorry you might be and so
if you go off and join Isis knowing what
they are knowing what they do and this
was in 2015 that she joined remember
this wasn't like she joined before
anyone had hardly even heard that the
the the name Isis I mean she joined in
2015
knowing very well that they kill and
rape children that they execute innocent
people that they lock people in cages
and set the cages on fire and those
sorts of things okay she knew this and
she still went and joined up and so that
is a choice that's going to haunt her
forever
she will experience the consequences
forever and some choices are like that
in fact you may argue that that every
choice is like that it's the part of
butterfly effect right butterfly flaps
is ring wings here and there's a tsunami
over in the you know on the other side
of the world so if you could argue that
every choice has has a ripple effect
that lasts in some sense forever but if
but if it's a if it's a very small
choice a choice that's no big deal
the the consequences will be possibly
imperceptible but if it's a big choice
if it's a choice like I'm joining Isis
if it's a if it's an I'm joining Isis
type decision then you'll probably never
outrun the consequences and that's just
the way it goes forgiveness really has
nothing to do with it
you just you just you're gonna have to
live with that now
and and also you know you're a danger to
society we don't know what kind of
radicalization you underwent
we don't know if this could be all some
kind of ploy on your part to get back
here and then do a terrorist attack I
mean these are all suspicions that we
are within our rights to have about you
and so you can you can just never come
back that's just that's just the way it
goes all right Jesse SMO let's is
officially under arrest
in custody charged with disorderly
conduct for filing a false police report
more charges will hopefully be be
forthcoming God willing if he did send
that hate letter to himself with the
white powder which I mean come on he
seems pretty likely to me that he did
but if he if he if they're gonna look
into that now and if he did send that
letter comes out that's gonna be a whole
new so this is just a charge for the
filing a false police report for the
fake attack that he staged if he sent
the letter to himself through the u.s.
mail with white powder in it then he
could be looking at some serious prison
time and so they're gonna be looking
into that as well I maintain that he
should be charged with a hate crime the
definition of a hate crime according to
the FBI is a criminal offense committed
against a person property or Society
that is motivated in whole or in part by
the offender's bias against a race
religion disability sexual orientation
or ethnicity / national origin
smollett's offense was indeed committed
against a society or a group which would
be white white people in this case white
conservatives in particular with the
objective of engendering outrage and
suspicion towards that entire group of
people in fact in fact his hatred of
white people was so great let's not
forget this Smollett was prepared to let
two innocent random white people take
the fall for this he was prepared to
have those people sent to prison for a
hate crime for something that he just
made up because you may recall that when
the police originally picked up the
purses of persons of interest that were
that you know that ended up being the
Nigerian brothers but before Smollett
knew that
he said he was he was fine with them
being arrested it was only after he
found out who they were that he said no
it couldn't have been them there's no
way it was them so if those were just
two random white people that got picked
up and this whole thing was pinned on
them smell that would be fine with that
just send these people to prison who did
absolutely nothing wrong so this is a
man who is a bigot and whose bigotry
constitutes a threat to civilized
society and he needs to face the
consequences face the consequences that
he would have happily allowed innocent
white men to face so I think he should
be charged with a hate crime but
certainly he needs to be charged with I
mean at a minimum if not that a host of
other crimes especially with the kind of
evidence they have against him speaking
of the evidence here is here is and this
came out last night right before they
arrested the guy here is surveillance
footage of the Nigerian brothers who he
hired to stage this attack here they are
buying ski masks and gloves on the night
of the attack look at this look at this
video they're buying a criminal starter
pack essentially they may as well be
wearing sandwich board signs that say we
are preparing to do something illegal
look at us like some Alette didn't think
to at least have these guys go to
different locations not in the city to
buy the stuff for the attack or at least
go buy the stuff at like a Walmart along
with other items to make it look less
suspicious you know go go pick up a
phone charger and box of saltine
crackers and some toilet paper some
Windex oh and the ski mask and some
gloves you know I mean he didn't at
least have him do that by buffer items
everyone knows that if you're going to
the grocery store you're buying
something embarrassing you buy buffer
like you don't go to the grocery store
and just buy one huge pack of toilet
paper right nobody does that because
then everyone in the store is gonna
think that you have explosive diarrhea
and you had to run to the store and buy
it all the toilet paper and you don't
want to do that so you go and you buy
other little
as well to go along with the toilet
paper to try to kind of take the edge
off and heat but he didn't have to do
that he just had him go to the store and
buy all the attack supplies on the night
of the attack I mean this guy is a total
[ __ ] he's a [ __ ] but he's also a
sociopath and I'd like to go back again
since we're looking at video knowing
what we know now I want to go back and
remember that interview that he gave
with Good Morning America soft total
softball interview but let's go back and
watch a piece of this interview knowing
everything that we know let's watch
especially this part right here look
look at this what do you say to a young
gay man a young gay person to learn to
fight and I don't just mean like we're
gonna fight I mean learn to fight learn
to be a fighter I am not advocating
violence at all so let's be clear about
that if you're gonna die fight until you
do because if you don't fight you have
no chance I have fought for love I'm an
advocate I respect too much the people
who I am now one of those people who
have been attacked in any way you do
such a disservice when you lie about
things like this if the attackers are
never found how will you be able to heal
boom I don't know let's just hope that
they are you know what I'm saying like
let's let's not go there yet
let's stop its I was talking to a friend
I said I just want them to find them and
she said sweetie they're not gonna find
them I just made me so angry because so
I'm just gonna be left here with this
you don't say it like I'm just gonna be
left here with with like so they get to
go free and go about their life and
possibly attack someone else and I'm
here to left look left with the
aftermath of this book
that's not cool to me that's not okay so
I understand how difficult it will be to
find them but we gotta I still want to
believe with everything that has
happened that there's something called
justice because if I stop believing that
then what's it all for
Thank You Jessie thank you thank you I
mean I'm not gonna say that he's a good
actor because I thought that it I
watched the interview when it happened
and I thought he came across completely
phony he he comes across like an actor
it seems like he's acting you could tell
that he even rehearsed some of those
lines you could tell that he was he who
knows maybe he had one of the Nigerian
brothers play the interviewer and they
went through they went through and
rehearsed the whole thing so he's not
even a very good actor but he is a
sociopath the fact that he could do that
at all the fact that he could sit there
and with for the most part a straight
face play this role is just incredible I
mean to be able to look someone in the
in the eyes and just lie to them just
with a completely made-up story to be
able to do that and he and he did that
for this was like a 15 minute interview
and he's sustained that eye contact and
he told this lie and he sort of sold it
I mean he did his level best that's why
I say this is someone who's a threat to
society and needs to go to prison for a
long time you just when you have someone
who is a pathological liar and is so
relatively well is you know it's not a
great liar but at least is a I don't
know I would give him I'd give him maybe
a six out of ten on the on the on the
convincing scale for that for that
interview so when you have someone who's
a decent is a pathological liar a
decently good liar and they're willing
to tell the most horrible kinds of lies
about people that I mean that is someone
who really is a threat and for the sake
of protecting society from his lies I
think it needs to go away to prison for
a very long time all right what else I
got to mention
because it's a huge controversy
controversy it's a huge controversy
there's a there's a new Ghostbusters
movie coming out but it's not gonna be
another all-female Ghostbusters like the
one that came out in 2016 which was
which was bad and it was a flop and it
was just bad that I mentioned bad this
new Ghostbusters is going to be a
continuation of the original
Ghostbusters franchise not the feminist
version and so the director of the
upcoming Ghostbusters Jason Reitman who
is I believe the son of the director of
the original Ghostbusters he was
interviewed this week and he said this
is a phrase used he said we're gonna
hand the movie back to the fans hmmm
gasp did you hear that we're gonna hand
the movie back to the fans
so that comment provoked a huge outrage
online huge outrage because because I
don't know because apparently it was
sexist to say we're gonna hate we're
going to hand the movie back to the fans
um this is a sexist comment now somehow
so for example just to give you an idea
of how people are taking this here's an
article on a website called the Mary Sue
calm kind of like a feminist seems to be
a relatively heavily trafficked feminist
website an article by Rachel Leishman
and this is not a joke by the way I mean
this is I don't think this is a teracle
I think this is a man to be totally
serious and the headline is giving
Ghostbusters back to the fans makes it
seem like women can't be Ghostbusters
fans
that's how feminists interpreted what
reitman said they interpreted as reitman
saying women aren't allowed to watch
this movie
what he said was we're gonna hand it
back to the fans what they heard was you
women can't watch this movie this is for
this here's for men go back in the
kitchen that's what they heard um I
don't I don't hear that I mean all I
hear is the guys saying we're gonna get
the movie back to the fans I don't hear
that other part of it
I don't but you see feminists they have
they can pick up a frequency they have I
think they have very finely tuned
hearing and so they can they can sort of
there are things that men say that that
are imperceptible to most of us because
it's not a different frequency but they
can hear the free that frequency and so
they heard reitman saying that sex is
common that none of us heard you see
here's a here's some of the article says
as someone who grew up watching the
Ghostbusters movies I would say very
confidently that I am a fan of Egon
Peter ray in Winston so to hear that
jason reitman who's directing the new
film plans to give it back to the fans I
honestly have to laugh are you laughing
though it seems like you're crying I
don't know if you're really laughing if
someone like myself and my older brother
can enjoy the Paul Feig version which is
the the feminist version what right does
Jason Reitman have to say that he's
giving the new film back to the fans I'm
sorry but maybe I'm confused doesn't
make me less of a fan that I like
ghostbusters answer the call
answer the call again as the feminist
version or am i less of a fan because
I'm a woman which one is it there Jason
Reitman as pudgy be' reports reitman is
supposedly letting the original fans
have their time again meaning they cried
enough on Twitter about the female
Ghostbusters that now the crybabies will
have their male centric comedy right
back where it started again this is not
a joke that means someone who really is
writing this in all sincerity on an
episode of Bill burns Monday Morning
Quarterback a Monday morning podcast
reitman said we are in everywhere in
every way trying to get back go back to
the original technique and hand the
movie back to the fans in case you had
any doubts as to what he means by that
he also said I'm not making the Junot of
Gus Ghostbusters movies another
important question I have is what this
means for Bill Murray and Ernie Hudson
two men who put their stamp of approval
on Ghostbusters answer the call remember
when they were in that film because
because because it gave fans and ode to
the original and was creative and funny
look I remember that time and geekdom my
young pseudo niece was terrified of
ghosts soda blah blah blah blah blah
right that we got past the funny parts
actually it was one other ok so dear mr.
Wrightman I know your father directed
the original film I get it you have a
claim to it but we do too we have a
claim to how these movies make us feel
and some of us enjoy to answer the call
so validating the most toxic
misogynistic opposition to that film as
the true fandom is a slap in the face to
all of us who felt empowered by the
female Ghostbusters was your intention
to alienate part of your fan base so
there were feminists who felt empowered
by a Ghostbusters film there were
feminists who watched a movie about
people fighting ghosts and they felt
empowered by that
may I suggest Rachel Wiseman that you
perhaps should look for your empowerment
in other places there are much better
sources for it I don't know read a book
about Joan of Arc or something uh if
you're looking for empowerment in
Ghostbusters films I just think you're
reading a little bit too much into it
this is one of my favorite things that
feminists do and and left us do in
general is uh they make a huge deal
about some really stupid thing and then
they accuse the other side of making a
big deal and so with the with the female
Ghostbusters the feminists latched on to
this movie and may turn it into this
turn it into the seminal moment in the
fight for women's rights as a female
Ghostbusters and they demanded that
everybody has to like this movie and
support it and laugh at it and think
it's funny and then a few people said
yeah you know what I really I just don't
have any interest in that I like the
original better I don't want to see it
and they're the ones who freaked out
over it it's it how dare you dislike
this Ghostbusters film you sexist but
then they turn around and cues us of
just because we didn't like the movie
and it's not even like we hated it or it
just it just wasn't a good movie and and
no I don't really feel like seeing the
feminist version of Ghostbusters you
know part of this is part of this with
with feminists is that they get very
touchy about anytime you even sort of
imply that a female comedian is not
funny
that's a lot of what this is about is
this is this is one of one of the big
things they're looking out for is anyone
who claims that female comedians aren't
funny or that women aren't as funny as
men and even though nobody was saying
that in regards to this movie they were
just saying this particular movie with
these comedians isn't that funny
we weren't making any statements about
female comedians in general but they get
feminist get very very sensitive about I
mean they get sensitive about everything
but especially about that and so I think
that was a that was a big part of it is
you know any female comedian we have we
must agree that she is funny every
female community they're all funny and
we're not allowed to say anything but
that and if we insinuate otherwise they
get um they get very offended all right
one other thing before we get to some of
your some of your emails on Tuesday as I
as I mentioned less on Tuesday Bernie
Sanders officially announced his 2020
presidential bid and he promptly raked
and I think it was six million dollars
in campaign donations within 24 hours of
that announcement so he obviously
remains an immensely popular figure on
the left and and the thing is even
people on the right
tend to attribute certain positive
qualities to him such as authenticity
and honesty
and I've heard plenty of Republicans
essentially say that well yeah I don't
like Bernie Sanders but he's the least -
he's the least repulsive Democrat on the
national stage which is hardly a high
honor or a high bar
to get over but I really don't think he
even makes it over that bar I don't
think he's the least repulsive III think
I'd put him more on the other end of
that spectrum ulcer in my opinion um and
it it and I think it's important for us
to recognize that because Sanders he's
got this kind of eccentric lovable
grandpa routine that he does and I think
a lot of people fall for it even on the
right and they see him as at worst a
kind of harmless eccentric old guy but
he's a lot worse than that he is in fact
and I wrote an article yesterday with
the title that Bernie Sanders is an
arrogant power-hungry hypocritical
cowardly morally deranged communist and
and I stand by that all of those
adjectives are carefully chosen and as I
did in the article I'll go I'll go
through them one by one to prove what
I'm talking about
so he's arrogant and power-hungry why is
it that well Bernie Sanders is 77 years
old if you were to be elected president
heaven help us he'd be 79 on
inauguration day
there's nothing wrong with being old
there's nothing wrong with being an
elderly person we will all be elderly
one day should we be so lucky as to live
that long but the presidency is an
enormous ly stressful physically taxing
mentally draining job there's a reason
why as I mentioned a couple days ago
just look at the you know Obama and Bush
went in the office as relatively young
men and they came out looking like the
life had been drained out of them
looking like they had aged 50 years both
of them so to think that you could take
on that kind of stress at the age of 80
you just have to be extraordinarily
arrogant to think to think that you
could handle that and you have to be
extraordinarily power-hungry to want it
I mean what 80 year-old man wants that
kind of stress well it's because if you
if you crave power that much see this is
this is the problem with presidents in
general this
it's kind of it's a problem that's baked
into the cake where the problem with
presidents is that they want so badly to
be president it's pretty it's uncommon
to have a reluctant leader make it into
the White House and I think we've gotten
to a point now in our society where it's
just where nobody like that is ever
going to be president ever again
the last one was probably Calvin
Coolidge there hasn't been any sense him
there was there were very few before him
what I'm talking about reluctant leaders
like guys who ran for president because
they think they have something to offer
they think that they can do the job but
they're not desperate for it they they
and and they you get the impression that
they'd be fine if they didn't win it
that really is that's the best we need
people with that attitude but it's just
if you have that attitude you probably
won't win because especially these days
to win you need to be very ruthless and
obsessed and and desperate basically and
so but a few of the presidents that
we've had who've who've been very
desperate for the job have been pretty
good at the job in spite of the
character flaw that prompted them to
pursue it in the first place
but the thing is it's it's
understandable to have that kind of
blind ambition is understandable for a
younger man but a man or woman who is
still grasping for the throne in his
final years of life someone who pursues
it even if it literally kills them in
the process that is a person we should
be very suspicious of so arrogant and
power-hungry Bernie Sanders is also
hypocritical Sanders has been living on
the public dime for 40 years during his
time as a public servant he has managed
to amass a fortune and a seven-figure
income especially over the last few
years that puts him firmly in that same
one percenter camp that he has spent
decades decrying he you know he hasn't
cashed in on his political career to the
same extent as say Hillary Clinton or
someone like that but he is no
middle-class hero that's for sure he
laments income inequality and meanwhile
he rails against the evils of capitalism
but he has done quite a bit of
capitalizing himself just a couple of
years ago he bought his third house
which is a modest little $600,000
lakefront property in Vermont now I
happen to believe that Americans are
entitled to buy as many homes as they
want and make as much money as the
market allows but I also believe in
being consistent and if somebody
lectures about greed and about
capitalism and about wealth all the time
and then and deliberately fosters hatred
and suspicion towards the wealthy with
this overheated kind of class warfare
rhetoric if that person goes and buys
three homes and collects millions in
book royalties well then they're going
to be guilty of rank hypocrisy most
Americans can't even afford one home
Sanders has three why doesn't he sell it
and use the money to pay off some
student loans or why doesn't he why
doesn't he donate all of the royalties
from his book from his from his books to
to soup kitchens in fact why is he
charging money for his books at all why
does he put his book online for free I
mean even Bernie's most dedicated fans
have to see the irony of a guy making
millions of dollars on a book which
advocates a socialist revolution Bernie
Sanders is also cowardly Sanders earned
a reputation as a kind of scrappy
freedom fighter who who stands up
against the dark and powerful forces in
our culture but he is not very
convincing and he's about as convincing
in that role as he is in the role of
middle class champion because it doesn't
take any courage for a Democrat to stand
up there and pump their fists and shout
about Wall Street and corporations and
so on but he there are powerful forces
in his own party
which it would require courage for him
to stand up against and which he does
not stand up against
and he should know about the powerful
forces the dark and powerful forces in
his party because they rigged the
primaries against him in 2016 yet in the
end he still bowed to the Clinton
machine he kissed the ring and he played
nice Bernie Sanders is morally deranged
and I could provide many examples here
but let's just start with his advocacy
his pro-abortion extremist advocacy
Bernie Sanders supports abortion at
every stage of pregnancy for any reason
he was asked in a debate in 2016 if he
could name one single circumstance where
he would support restrictions on
abortion and he could not name one there
is no circumstance no situation at any
point of pregnancy for any reason where
he thinks that abortion should be
illegal and there's more Sanders is also
a a lifelong communist he is on tape in
the 80s heaping praise on Fidel Castro
admitting that he provided advice to the
Sandinistas in Nicaragua Nicaragua
you know Sanders the the Bernie's
communism is more than just a
personality quirk okay he has been
providing PR cover two murderous
communist regimes for decades now
Sanders as we've already established is
no spring chicken okay this is not a
young guy he's not some stupid college
student who champions communism because
he doesn't know what happened in the
world prior to about 2005 no he lived
through the majority of the 1900s and he
knows very well that it was a century
bathed in the bloodshed in in in in
bloodshed by communist governments he
knows that he knows very well that
communist government governments very
recently killed 100 million people and
Counting yet he
for communist policies and wishes to see
the great evil of the 20th century
reborn in the 21st and in what else can
we call that but morally deranged you
support a system that once again killed
100 million people at a minimum and
Counting since the beginning of the of
the of the 20th century that is morally
deranged so the ideas that Bernie
Sanders espouses aren't just wrong or
radical they are wicked and he espouses
them in a hypocritical fashion steeped
in cowardice and arrogance he is not
suited for the Senate much less the
White House and that's why I say that he
is an arrogant power-hungry cowardly
morally deranged communist fraud and god
help us if he ever makes it to the White
House though I doubt that that will
happen all right um nobody gets oh just
a couple of emails today you can email
the show at matt walsh show at gmail.com
matt walsh OU gmail.com this is from
this is a big question from Anthony it
says hi Matt I've been a fan for a while
I really value your opinion and
perspective mainly because I agree with
you on most things so my sorry I did
that was kind of funny I value your
opinion because I agree with you so my
wife and I have recently returned to
Christianity last November we returned
to the church I was wondering if you
could help us with understanding how God
can have a plan yet we are free to make
choices even sinful ones how are we
created in the image of God and created
by God yet there are evil people why
would God purposefully create people who
he knows will be evil thank you very
much my wife and I really enjoy your
show hope you can provide some clarity
on this or some ideas on where I could
find some clarity have a wonderful day
god bless hi Anthony and welcome back to
the faith you are dealing with one of
the most maybe the most difficult
theological question so the fact that
you can't quite figure it out is nothing
to be embarrassed by because nobody I
mean it's it there there is no perfect
answer for it there is no answer that I
can give that will make you go okay well
I totally get that now then you know as
far as where you can find answers I
would recommend as I've recommend on the
show before the problem of pain by CS
Lewis it's a very short book it's a
short concise very kind of tight
efficient answer to this problem not so
much an answer but a it's a treatment of
the problem and you're gonna find much
more wisdom on one page of that book
than I could give you if I'd rambled
about this for the next three hours
which I promise I won't but go and read
that book what I will say is the answer
the Christian answer classically and I
think the correct answer is it hinges on
freewill
so God gave us the power to choose to
act to decide to distinguish one thing
from another and if we can choose one
thing or another that means that we can
choose evil we can choose to do wrong
why does he allow us this choice well
because you can't have love without
choice you can't have joy you can't have
goodness you can't have courage or
fidelity or any virtue because all of
that is meaningless if we are just
programmed automotives so think about it
if you talk about drone strikes earlier
I nobody credits a drone with courage
right when you hear about a drone strike
of Isis you don't say Wow well that was
a courageous drone that drone really we
got to give that drone some credit but
let's go let's give it let's give a
Medal of Honor to the to the drone we
don't say that about drones we do say
that about the men who stormed the
beaches of Normandy why is that well
because the one is just a program the
machine it had no choice but to do what
it did you don't you don't get any
credit for it for
doing something you had no joy no choice
but to do and more to the point it's
hard to even say that you did that thing
if you had no choice but to do it if
somebody grabs your hand and and puts a
gun in it and forces you to pull the
trigger well then we can't even say that
you shot someone you didn't really do
that it was the person who grabbed your
hand who did that and you really had no
role you were just a pawn
you were just a an instrument and and
nothing more so it you know so the man
who stormed the beaches of Normandy we
say that they had courage because they
had a choice and in that choice is the
courage is the valor is the virtue if
they didn't have a choice if they didn't
have the option of cowardice then they
wouldn't have had the option of courage
just like you can't go up if there is no
down if there if down does not exist it
doesn't mean anything to go up because
then there is only up right so so that's
it in order to in order to have love and
goodness and all that it needs to be
chosen and if if there's going to be a
choice then there has to be an opposite
that could be chosen and that's where
you find the evil and the suffering and
the pain now I admit that that's only a
partial answer okay that deals with the
suffering and evil that we inflict on
each other and I think that that pretty
well deals with that there's a whole
other question though about the pain and
suffering that people suffer that people
deal with that does not appear to be
chosen you know a child getting cancer
for instance child didn't choose that
nobody chose that just happened that's a
much more difficult question to deal
with and one that again I I can't I
can't give you some concise cute little
answer that will make you say okay well
that's it but I would recommend that
that book
you all right this is from Mary says hey
Matt I'm 20 years old Catholic
conservative my dad got your book the
unholy trinity for his birthday two
years ago and when he finished it I
started reading it it was fantastic
loved every minute of it when I read
that book I didn't know very much about
politics now I try my best to be as
knowledgeable as I can I also listened
to your show fairly often it's good to
listen to while I'm doing housework I'm
the oldest of 10 children so the house
gets messy a lot I can imagine we only
have three kids and you should see our
house a lot of the time I feel like I
should ask you a question
which of the Lord of the Rings movies is
your favorite the extended versions of
course anyway love your work
praying for all the best for you your
wife and your children may God and all
his goodness bless you Mary that was
such a nice email that I now I don't
even want to give you the answer that I
was prepared to give I feel bad saying
this to you but I have to tell you that
I have I have recently come to the
conclusion that the Lord of the Rings
movies are massively overrated
the books are great but I did go back
recently and try to watch the movies and
they're not as good as I remember so I
can't I don't know if I can I don't
think they hold up as well as I thought
they would a little too sappy a little
bit corny kind of drawn-out too long
that was just my impression I don't even
know if I can answer that question
anymore I just am I I just made this
discovery recently my whole world is
rocked by it as you can tell I'm sort of
emotionally I'm very confused and I'm in
a bit of emotional chaos over this
because I had always thought of Lord of
the Rings movies one of the best film
maybe the best film franchise well
second to the The Godfather which does
hold up by the way and but I just I
don't know if this if this if this is
that anymore and I really I really hate
to to tell you that I
I'm afraid that Lord of the Rings might
be like the Star Wars films in being it
might join in the Star Wars films France
the Star Wars franchise as and
be the second most overrated film
franchise behind Star Wars but thank you
for watching the show anyway and I
appreciate the question and I'll talk to
you guys tomorrow Godspeed